What I want to do in
this video is really make
some clarifications and go
a little bit more in detail
about the different
layers of the earth.
So let me draw a cross-section
of the earth over here.
And I'll try to do it.
I won't be able to do
it perfectly to scale,
but I'll try to do a little
bit better job at giving you
a little bit of a sense of
how thick these layers are.
So let's say that this
is the crust up here.
And I'm going to make
the continental crust
a little bit thicker.
So let's say that that
is continental crust
and this is continental crust.
And then in between, let me
put some oceanic crust, which
is going to be thinner.
Actually, let me do that
in a different color.
Let me do the oceanic
crust in blue.
But this isn't water.
This is rock.
I'll do it in purple.
That's even better.
I don't want it
to be that thick.
So let me draw the
oceanic crust-- is thinner
than the continental
crust, which
I'm trying to depict
right over here.
So this right over
here is oceanic crust,
and up here is
continental crust.
And the thickness, or how
deep you can go and still
be in crust, it depends
on where you are.
And we know that near hot spots,
the oceanic crust can actually
thin out a good bit.
But roughly, when we
talk about the crust,
we're talking about
something that's
30 to 60 kilometers deep.
So 30 to 60 kilometers deep.
So if you are on
a continent, which
I'm assuming you are, and
you dig for 20 kilometers,
you will still be in the crust.
30 kilometers, probably
still in the crust.
If you dig for 70 kilometers
or 100 kilometers,
you will probably
reach the mantle.
And remember, what
we're describing here,
when we talk about the crust,
the mantle, and the core,
we're talking about
the chemical makeup.
Let me make this clear.
We're talking about
the chemical makeup.
The crust is fundamentally
different than the mantle based
on the molecules that
it is made up of,
based on its composition.
So let's talk about
the mantle now.
So the mantle, layer like this.
And once again, this is not
to scale because the crust,
we're talking about
30 to 60 kilometers.
The mantle, we're talking
about on the order
about 2,900 or 3,000
kilometers thick.
So this right here
is the entire mantle.
So that's the mantle.
And this is 2,900 to
3,000 kilometers thick.
So this isn't even 1/30 of that.
So I would have to draw it
even narrower than the way
I've drawn it over here.
And the mantle itself
can be subdivided
into the upper mantle
and the lower mantle.
So let me draw this
division right over here.
The upper mantle, and
there's different ways
to define the boundary.
The upper mantle is roughly
about 700 kilometers down.
So these are huge distances.
I mean, this is
going straight down.
So this is the upper mantle.
Let me write it on the
actual mantle here.
This is the upper mantle,
and this over here
is the lower mantle.
And just to be clear on things.
So the crust is solid.
Now when you go into
the upper mantle,
the upper part of the
upper mantle-- and we'll
talk about that a
little bit more--
is cool enough to be solid.
So there is a solid portion
of the upper mantle.
So all of this up here is
solid because it's cool enough.
It hasn't reached the melting
point of those rocks just yet.
And we learned in
previous videos
that the combination of the
solid part of the upper mantle
and the crust combined, we
call that the lithosphere.
And when we talk
about the lithosphere,
we're not talking about
the mechanical makeup.
We're not talking about what's
solid and what's not solid.
So this is the lithosphere.
You go a little bit deeper.
Right below the lithosphere,
now the temperatures
are high enough for-- and
I use the word liquid,
but that's not exactly right.
You can kind of think of it
as kind of a deformable solid,
or a plastic solid or a magma.
And that's the asthenosphere.
So this area right over
here, this area right
over here, the liquid
part-- actually, I
shouldn't use the word liquid.
Kind of deformable.
It deforms over long
periods of time.
But it is more fluid
than what we normally
associate with rock
magma, would be a good way
to think about it.
That's what we call
the asthenosphere.
It is fluid, just not
as fluid as water.
It is more viscous than
something like water.
So this is the asthenosphere.
Now the upper mantle,
it's hot enough
for the rock to
melt and be fluid.
And the pressure is
low enough for it
to still be able to kind
of move past itself,
to still be somewhat fluid.
But then once you get even
deeper, into the lower mantle,
you have higher pressure.
And so it's still fluid,
but it's less fluid.
It's kind of thicker--
I guess, is the best
way to think about it-- in the
lower mantle, it's thicker.
So this whole area over
here, you could kind of
think of it as melted rock.
It's fluid.
But the upper part of the
melted rock is more fluid.
It's able to move easier,
because there's less pressure.
And the pressure's just from
all of the rock that's above it.
Remember, gravity is
pulling down on everything.
Every molecule here wants to
go downward because of gravity.
So it's applying
pressure downward.
So the deeper you go, the
more pressure you get.
Now, when we get even deeper
than that, we get to the core,
and the core is divided
between the outer core
and the inner core.
So the outer core
and then, of course,
you have the inner core.
And just so we have a
sense for the distances,
the width or the thickness
of the outer core
is approximately
2,300 kilometers.
So these are huge distances,
when you think about thickness.
You could go down
another 2,300 kilometers,
and you're in the-- or once
you go through the mantle,
you can go 2,300 kilometers
to the outer core.
And then you're
in the inner core
and that essentially
takes you to the rest.
That's essentially the
center of the earth.
And the inner core--
Maybe I should
draw the boundaries a
little bit more to scale.
Let me do it this way.
It should actually
look a little bit more
like this, because
the outer core
is thicker than the inner core.
So the outer core is, as
I said, let me rewrite it.
Outer core is on the order, it's
about 2,300 kilometers thick.
And then you have
your inner core.
I shouldn't do it in blue.
I should do it in a hot color.
So the inner core
right over here
just kind of takes us to
the center of the earth.
And that's a little over
1,000 kilometers thick.
So this is the inner core.
The number I have is about
1,200 kilometers thick.
And both the-- the entire
core, both the outer core
and the inner core, is
mainly nickel and iron.
Think about when the
earth was forming.
What happens is when this
whole earth was super hot
and was kind of
in a fluid state,
the heavier elements
were allowed
to sink down, when
everything was fluid.
The things that were in
between would kind of--
or the things that were
lighter would go up.
And then the gases, things
that would naturally
be in the gaseous
state, would kind of
bubble up through that
fluid, kind of the way,
actually, carbon
bubbles up in a soda,
it would eventually
bubble out of the fluid,
and it would actually
form the atmosphere.
So that's why, when you look at
the composition of the earth,
you have the densest,
the heaviest elements,
at the center.
And then the lightest elements
are forming the atmosphere.
And the outer core and
the inner core, they
are made up predominantly
of nickel and iron.
And their makeup is
actually very similar.
So this division--
Chemically, they
have a very similar composition.
What's different about
them is at the outer core,
you have temperatures
high enough
that nickel and iron can melt.
But the pressures are low
enough that they can still
be in a fluid state.
So this is our
liquid outer core.
And this has a
pretty low viscosity,
especially even
relative to the mantle.
So that's why people
kind of consider
this in kind of a more
traditional liquid state.
But as you get deeper
and deeper and deeper,
the pressure becomes
so huge as you
get to the inner core-- remember
all of the weight of all
of the rock above you, of these
thousands of miles of rock
above you, is all pushing
down on the rock below it.
So the inner core, even though
the temperature is really,
really, really hot,
the pressure is so big
that the molecules can't
flow past each other.
They can't be liquid.
They're kind of jam-packed.
And so the inner core,
because of the high pressure,
despite the high
temperature, is solid.
It's solid.
So the difference
here is actually
a mechanical one between the
outer core and the inner core.
They're made up of the
same things, roughly
the same chemical makeup.
It's just slightly-- or
lower pressure on the outside
so you can actually
be in a fluid state.
So hopefully that
clarifies and gives you
a little bit of depth on
the makeup of the earth.